s for
[Silence]
asbar allahar
allaham
[Silence]
as
f
[Silence]
allahar ill
alhamdulillah
[Silence]
subh
s
[Silence]
my dear brothers respected Elders
beloved youth mothers and sisters we
thank Allah subhana tala for keeping us
alive one more day on the path of Islam
on the in allowing me and you to enter
his house and worship him in that matter
that pleases him I ask Allah subh accept
from me and except from you that little
we do in his path a mean and I bear
witness there is no deed worthy of
worship except for Allah subhana tala
and Prophet Muhammad sahu alai wasallam
is his last and final messenger for
surely who Allah subhana TAA chooses to
guide n can misguide and whoever chooses
to misguide that should guide him back
to the path and we seek refuge in Allah
from darkness of ourselves and evil of
our Deeds for Allah is all knowing and
all seeing what his creation
does it's been a little while since I
last met you guys from the member of
alai wasallam and the last time I was
here we at least I feel I touched
on a topic that needs to be further
investigated and talked about and that
one probably is not suffice or wasn't
suffice or maybe this is not going to be
sufficed either for that topic
subsequently after the I had some
brothers come up to me and say brother
great topic alhamdulillah we we liked it
now can you talk about the rights of a
mother so if you remember last time we
when I spoke on the it was talking about
women and the rights and as a husband
what we have to do and not do and we
talked about some examples from
the in the but we did not get too too
deep into it now first and
foremost with all due respect you
know we're we're we're just Homo sapiens
right we're just glorified monkeys so to
speak walking around on this face on
this face of the Earth we're just just
human beings and part of being a human
is a lot of times as we know most of us
who have children it's not what we tell
them it's what they see us do and they
act it
out a lot of times you catch your kid
and you ask him hey where did you learn
that and he will tell you oh I saw it on
TV and you're but I told you that
that's just a movie don't pay he's like
no no no but that person does it in in
the TV and and I haven't had this
conversation with my child and I have to
explain over and over again that's just
a movie it's not real that's not what
people do around their life when they
walk around so first and foremost when
we talk about the respect and the
Dignity of a mother the the child or the
children in the house will see what
their father is doing with their mother
and treat her accordingly to that
level now some of you might say well I
don't agree with that but that's the
reality of life we imitate things around
us and we Act
accordingly if they see a father who
never is in the kitchen helping the
mother out who comes home and drops
everything everywhere the shoes are here
the clothes are there the stuff is there
and she's responsible whether she is
sick or well she is unwell or bearing a
child and that's her responsibility the
child the young man in the house is
going to grow up and repeat the same
patterns when he is married in his
lifetime so as such for me the the the
main issue is
what tells us and I I'll say something
here you know on a scholarly level there
is a debate between on the
of we have that are and there that are
meaning when he told somebody to do
something of an action for example he
told to make
from is that he himself did not make Om
from there but he made it his Nia from
the mik coming from Medina for some the
latter is more honorable because he
sallallah alaih wasallam did it himself
and for some the former is more better
because heam told somebody else to do it
so there's a constant debate but in this
matter there should not be a debate
it should be simple now look at the life
of when he gets Revelation in the cave
of hell he comes down from the mountain
and a Hadith mentioned mention
that was very unwell in a sense that he
was
terrified he thought that he had seen an
operation he had seen a ghost he might
have been possessed there was something
evil happening so who does he run to in
that state and by the way some
narrations go as far as he wanted to
throw himself from the mountain because
he was so conflicted about what had
happened to him imagine you in a cave
not modern day where you have your
battery packs and your you know LED
light packs with your cell phone has a
camera and reception but it's a pitch of
dark in the pitch of night the whole
city has no
electricity it's dark and something
appears out of them blue literally just
appears in front of you and
says and this is something that he's
dealing with now so he's coming down
from the mountain and where does he run
to does he go to his family does he go
to his uncles his cousins no he goes
home to his
wife he goes home and tells her kah I
have seen this and she is the first
person to embrace him physically and
spiritually and morally and he he says
to him
y you've always been kind to the people
you give to the poor you take care of
the needy Allah will not leave you
alone and then her wisdom S surprise you
know goes beyond that and she says okay
let me take you to one of my cousins
that I know who happened to be on the
true Dean of n of the Christianity at
that time he was truly believing in the
commands of Allah subhana taala and then
he affirms it that that thing that
visited you
is and you have gotten the
Revelation and he goes further and
divulges into it a time will come if I
was alive I will defend you andam asked
him defend me from what and he says
they're going to kick you out of your
own City he says me my people will kick
me out say yeah your people will kick
you out of your
city let's take the second point
from wasam comes one day to the house
and he tells and he sits down and he is
he is so depressed he's so worried and
his face shows
it
so enters the room and says what is
wrong with you and he opens up to her
and he says listen there is so much need
around that I see every day people who
need help people who need food they need
clothing they need other amenities they
need Necessities in their life I cannot
provide she goes to the Next Room brings
a
and the Hadith mentions that she kept
spilling the money piling in front of
him I mean back then we had coins right
so the coins are being piled up and
wasallam is is is smiling and the pile
becomes so high that he is literally
hidden behind
it and she says go go and do what you
want to do with
this now that is a
status of a
woman look at the treatment look at the
examples of
the it's the wife who is upholding her
husband did she know at that time he was
going to be a prophet no did she know
after he came down from the cave that he
was a prophet
no but that was her wisdom Allah had
given him the intellect to go beyond
what she was just physically seeing and
become the rock of her
husband even
when is in Medina and he's remarried now
to
other you know ctis son of him
he something will come in the house of
so he will
tell send it to friends
of to a point that AA becomes jealous
and she said w
every time something comes in the house
a gift you always say to give it to that
friend of that friend
ofad soam
told she believed in me when nobody else
would believe in me she stood by me when
nobody else stood by me she was my
support what there was no support so how
can I not honor her friends as such
this is
the and it is necessary for us from time
to time to go visit it you know with all
due respect we live in a world today
where this word the four-letter word has
become a a stigma l o v
e but do you love me love is a skewed
concept my my my dear brothers and
sisters it's a skewed concept so you
have to understand love is I say I love
my brother so and so
because because there is a because in
it because he is nice to
me you often ask young children do you
love your mom or dad more they always
say oh I love my mom why because she
cooks for
me or I love my dad because you know he
buys me candies all the time even though
my mom tells me not to but he takes me
out and buys me candy all the time
or he takes me out he says Hey sh
there's no Sora in the house but guess
what just drink all the Sora you want so
the love the concept love is cute
because it is there's something else
after
it I love so and so why because I love
visiting that country
because that concept of love is not
something Allah subhana tala has
mentioned in the Quran between a husband
and a
wife is something Allah has talked about
and mu itself is not
love it is not
love if you really want to go dig down
deep it's compassion and mercy between
the husband and the
wife so this concept this modern day
concept is destroying our households in
a sense is destroying our mentality
because for some reason there has to be
an equation of Love
somewhere and that's not how life
works that's not how Allah subhana tala
has told us about the relationship
between a husband and a
wife compassion and
mercy the two Essential Elements you
will need to make any relationship work
but more than so a husband hband and a
wife
relationship you
know and I always mention the she always
used to say if you want Flavor in Your
Gatherings mention the the of
so is is Theif in Medina a man comes one
day to his
house with some need and back then you
know the houses didn't have Gates and
walls we do today so it's just
basically a cloth hanging on the door so
he comes to the house and he
hears from
inside that om's wife is is going at him
verbally they're having she's having an
argument one-sided argument with him and
she's telling him you know you're busy
XYZ you never have time for the house
you're Khalifa you're such an important
men so and so you're always busy with
others Affairs but you don't have time
for your own household you we all have
heard that somewhere along the way in
our lives right you always have time for
the other people you don't have time for
us in the house may Allah subh make it
easier for all of us so the man is
standing there and you know he hears it
and then you know he says okay you know
that's enough so he turns around and
leaves and om sees him sees him from
inside leaving so he walks behind and
says stop stop stop you came for
something what is your what is your need
he says moment it's okay he says no
no no no I saw you at the door brother
can tell me he says the reason I came to
your door you have the same problem in
your
house so so let's leave it at
that so Omar looks at him and he says my
wife cooks for me she cleans for me she
washes my clothes for me she raises my
children for me she takes care of my
house she doesn't let anybody else enter
my house or never sleep on my bed
another man can can enter my house and
sleep on my bed so what from time to
time if she's frustrated and she raises
her are waste to me it's
okay you know and that's the concept and
that's why I mentioned what Allah
subhana has mentioned Surah ayat 21
often times that I has recited in a time
of when people are getting married right
that compassion and
mercy because that's what we needed to
make the wheels work in our life as we
know the story of creation
ha was created from the left rib of
Adam and as such has said there's always
going to be a bend in the rib rib is
never straight if you try to straighten
it it will crack and if you let it go it
will become more bent so a proper amount
of give and take works in the
household and that is what your children
are observing day in and day
out they will observe this and tomorrow
when they have their own households they
will follow that example knowingly or
unknowingly because they've been
programmed with that
subconsciously who's going to cook food
it's her responsibility who's going to
do the laundry it's her responsibility
when we have a Hadith blatantly
saying used to help in the household
chores he will sww his own clothes he
will mend his own shoes
let me finish with
this mentioned
to one day and pay attention by the way
this is this is what tells you thatat
was a human being living in a human
world he
says I know when you're happy with me
and when you are unhappy with me you're
not happy with me and he says she says y
Allah how do you know and he says you
know when you take a swear when you Oath
by Allah when you're happy with me you
say Muhammad you include my name with
Allah's name but then when you're not
happy with me you say IIM same but I you
remove the name and he she says you're
100% accurate when I'm not happy with
you I just remove your name from that
but I still swear by Allah subhana wa
tala and this is tell this what tells
you this is the prophet of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala this is the man who did not
need anything you know convenience wise
you know to go from in one night from
from from mecah to to from there to
heavens and he was back in no time right
if he can achieve that what else can
they achieve what Allah could not bless
them with but these things in the life
of the are there to show us that yes
there are difficulties there are issues
but our job is to deal with it in a
proper
manner we are to deal with it in a good
manner a marriage is not a
dictatorship it's a balancing
act sometimes she listens sometimes you
have to
listen she gives and you give
too and if anything that needs to be
produced and reproduced on a daily basis
it's not a onetime pill my brothers and
my
sisters you know I I don't have a magic
potion you know I'm married too so I go
I go with the same issues that everybody
else goes with we deal with the same
issues that everybody else deals
with but it's a give and take in
following the of wasam I ask Allah subh
to protect our pry from going astray we
ask Allah subh to protect our households
from evil eyes and from the magic and
the Hass of people
we ask Allah subh to make an that is
an in a true sense in the path ofi
wasallam and we are Muslims in a true
sense where the life of wasallam becomes
a mirror to us so we can follow it in
the proper path and we get closer to
Allah subhana tala through that act and
become those people where wasallam told
us from one thing that we follow it in
an appropriate way and if he stopped us
from one thing we follow it in the same
way and may Allah subh protect us from
all the sh and the evil that is around
us today especially you know the the
most heinous or the most abundant
used is to separate a husband and a wife
may Allah protect us all we ask Allah to
create ease in our lives and may Allah
subh gather us he is gathered today
in The Gardens of paradise
[Silence]
alhamdulillah you know I had I had
couple of more Hadith discuss but subh
the time is is just flown by one of the
one of theith that I mentioned last
week I repeat it again inallah for
myself first and foremost for everybody
else he said best of you is the one who
is best to his family and I'm the best
of you because I am the best to my
family so we have to have that as a
guiding source of guidance the other
Hadith I want to mention I want to
finish on this on this note because this
is an amazing note to to understand the
life of
alam mentioned in there's several
narrations on this on this topic that
there was there was an incident there
was there was some people that were
visiting from from Ethiopia to to
Medina and they happened to be acrobats
they had some some skills where they
were showing some sword play some other
things in the in the
m and and wanted to to see some of the
acrobatics that was going on so the
Hadith mentions
that wasam made his his his th that His
Garment over
covering she stood behind him and rested
her chin on his
shoulder can you can you picture a more
more beautiful
couple her her chin is on his shoulder
and his cloak is covering her and him at
the same time and she's watching in the
Masjid they're standing in the doorway
of
the and watching in the Masid this this
war game so to speak that's going on
these young men are showing their skills
of sword fighting and various things and
the Hadith mentions
blatantly
that stood there
until herself had enough and then walked
back in the
house and that proves to you the love
well no not the love let me go back the
compassion and the mercy had this is the
beautiful Bond Allah subhana tala has
created for
us if you if you're just joining and the
reason I took back the word love is
because I said love is skewed the word
is very skewed you love somebody because
there's always because and compassion
and mercy does not need that requirement
of because
so as we leave
today go forth and try to replicate the
life
of you know I'll finish with this not
because I see some of you getting
serious I just leave you with something
smiling because that's Sunnah
too you know one of the sh just like
me poor guy gave a lecture one day on
the member he said you know be nice to
your wives go home and appreciate their
cooking and XYZ so the man went home and
she had a the wife had some dinner ready
for him and he ate it and he said
mashallah this is is the best food I
ever had and she stood up and told him
oh okay I see how it is and she he said
what it's great food you made excellent
food she said all my life I made food
for you today the neighbor sent food and
you it so you know just be careful
just be careful before you go home and
you know do that thing insh make sure
she cooked it first you know I don't
know check a camera or something I don't
know I told you you want to keep leave
you smiling but you know within within
those you know within those jokes
there's seriousness W this is a this is
an issue that is is haunting our umah
you know and I said this last time I
was here just the sheer phone calls for
counseling and issues that I have on a
weekly basis and a monthly basis is
immense and it breaks your heart it
tears you up to see how how how our umah
is is
befallen to such such you know disasters
because we have chosen to give up the
and I'm being blatant W you know there
is no reason for us to be stray because
when Allah
says he says you know in the Quran that
I today I have finished your religion
for you I've perfected your religion so
it's a perfect religion we're imperfect
human beings so we make Dua to Allah
subh T to create us to make us into a
perfect human being to give us the light
of theam and his Sunnah so we can follow
upon his path and so we can end up
drinking the water from the house of on
the day of from the hand ofu alaih
wasallam and may be not the ones who are
pushed away from that water because we
went
[Silence]
astray for
please move forward
[Silence]
strain your lines fill the gaps in
between may Allah subh have mercy upon
us Allah
alhamdulillah
[Silence]
amen for
allahar Allah abbar
[Silence]
allahar
allahar alhamd
Al
[Silence]
amen for
allahar
allahar Allah I
[Silence]
allahar allahar
Allah
[Silence]
asalamu
brothers and sisters asalam
alaikum couple of quick reminders Sunday
school is back in session so if you have
children of the school age can you
please visit with Imam Hassan and he'll
get you all set up inshallah again
Sunday school is back in session
starting this Sunday so you should be
able to benefit from that there's a
Quran brother ob's Mother passway in in
Pakistan there will Bean tonight
after or 5:30 inshallah 5:30 to 8 I
think that's the timing so if you want
to join
inshallah also there is a documentary
Tomorrow there's a review of the
documentary and the title of that is
where the olive trees weep if you want
to benefit from that please enroll in
that on online and that's going to be
tomorrow Saturday at 1:30 p.m.
inshallah also we have a special box now
for Masid expansion so as you know the
construction is in progress so if you
want to contribute be to that inshallah
use that box and donate generously
[Silence]
you know French
if you can go this
way it has to be a two-way stre
[Silence]
I say
cor no one knows
[Silence]
yeah know it's good
see help
[Silence]
he for
all